behold this infinite mathematical
Universe a dizzying Cascade of fractals
arrays of complex patterns filled with
both satisfying self-similarity and
surprising novel features all of the the
structure and the patterns that you see
there really do exist for a reason there
is some sort of innate mathematical
cause behind all of the phenomenon that
you see this is the Mandel BR set these
trippy images represent a form of modern
algorithmic exploration one made
possible by
computers a handful of mathematicians
have devoted their lives to uncovering
this set Secrets it plays this very
Central role in our understanding of
much much more complicated systems it is
Step number one and we may be on the
verge of finally understanding it so
what exactly is the Mandel BR set and
how does it
work the Mandel BR set is a perfect
example of how a simple rule can produce
incredible complexity at its core the
set is generated by iterating a
quadratic equation a simple formula
whose highest exponent is 2 to iterate a
quadratic equation choose a value for
the variable plug it into the function
then take the output and feed it back in
again and
again the study of how recursive
functions like these change over time is
Central to a field of mass called
complex dynamical systems this subject
came about with the goal of
understanding The Real World what are
the mathematics that underly the
physical world that we see most
important early example would have been
the solar system so dynamical systems
that you have some space where you have
some rule that's assigning as time moves
on how that space evolves and how things
move and change in the early 20th
century mathematicians Pierre Fatu and
Gaston Julia set the St stage for the
discovery of the mandal Bron set with
their exploration of dynamical systems
to investigate these dynamical systems
mathematicians study intricate shapes
today known as Julia sets Julia sets are
produced by iterating a function of
complex numbers a complex number is
defined as the sum of two components a
real part and an imaginary part each
complex number can be visualized as a
point in a 2d
plane the real part is a number found on
the number line the imaginary part is a
multiple of the square root of -1 which
mathematicians write as I despite the
name imaginary numbers play a vital role
in solving real world problems to
construct a jeulia set start with the
simple quadratic equation F of z = z ^2
+ C choose a value for c like1 for
example then consider what happens when
you iterate this equation for every
every possible starting value you
repeatedly apply the function to this
sequence of numbers that you're
generating and you ask whether or not
that sequence is going off to infinity
or whether it stays bounded for some
initial values your equation speeds off
to Infinity when iterated like this
these values are not in a Julia set when
you start iterating from other initial
values you might instead get a sequence
of outputs that stay bounded when
something comes back to itself often we
call that current behavior and that's
where the complexity arises the boundary
between points that stay bounded and
those that don't is a Julia set you can
fill it in by including all the bounded
values different quadratic equations
generate a wide range of filled Julia
sets from basic blobs to intricate
twisting
tendrils fil Julia sets can be divided
into two categories sets where you can
draw a line from one point to any other
without lifting your pen are connected
sets where points look like scattered
pieces of dust are
disconnected the first rough plot of the
mandle BR set appeared in a 1978 paper
by the mathematicians Robert Brooks and
J Peter matelski soon after Ben wall
mandoob a researcher at IBM who had
access to more computing power also
discovered the set this led to further
Explorations these early computer
Graphics were crude but the patterns
revealed the Pres of something far more
complex even with like fuzzy like poorly
made pictures in the in the 80s they
were able to really glean a lot of
interesting insight into what's going on
mandal BR went on to popularize his Now
anonomous set to the world and became
known as the father of fractals today
mathematicians can use computers to
explore the Mando BR set in far greater
detail as soon as you have images just
opens up this whole world
the Mandel BR set is drawn in the
complex plane it's constructed by
iterating the same quadratic equations
used to produce Julia sets but here
things are flipped around instead of
iterating all values of Z for a fixed
value of C we fix the starting value of
the iteration at zero and Vary C values
of c where iterations of z^2 plus C stay
bounded are inside the mandal BR set
while those that go to Infinity are not
here we can select points inside the
Mandel BR set to reveal their
corresponding fi Julia sets the Mandel
BR set acts like an atlas cataloging the
different kinds of Julia sets values of
c inside the mandal BR set are
associated with connected Julia sets
while values outside the set correspond
with disconnected
dust the mandro set has many intriguing
features but its biggest mysteries lie
in its complex fr fractal
boundary zooming in to different
boundary regions reveals some astounding
features a valley of
seahorses parades of
elephants and miniature versions of the
set itself so we can sort of keep
finding nests a sequence of smaller and
smaller M brets all one inside of the
next here at the boundary mathematicians
are probing for answers as you look at
it it sort of seems like one blob but if
you really ask like is it all connected
or maybe if I zoom in Far Enough there's
some separating piece this question is
Central to a 40-year-old problem called
the Mando locally connected conjecture
or
mlc if the set is locally connected that
means that no matter what point you
choose to examine or how far you zoom in
the area will always look like one nice
connected section for example if we
closely examine a circle we can see that
it's locally connected at every point
but take a Vine toothed comb and zoom in
while the comb is one connected shape at
close range it can look
disconnected if mathematicians can prove
that mlc is true then a complete
understanding of the Mandel BR set would
be within reach this local connectivity
question if we can answer it if it can
be solved this will give us almost
complete control and understanding of
what's going on the hope is that once we
completely understand quadratic
polinomial we can go on to looking at
more complicated
dynamical systems and be able to
describe them more and more but a full
understanding of the Mand BR set
wouldn't put an end to our Collective
fascination with this famous fractal
hard to imagine that it wouldn't be
interesting to people even if we fully
understood it because it is so
complicated and so rich and so
[Music]
beautiful